this is a really fascinating remarkable
story here new court documents reveal
why US soccer says women should not get
paid as much as men the US Soccer
Federation argues it's not violating the
Equal Pay Act since the job of the men's
national team quote carries more
responsibility and requires a higher
level of skill based on speed and
strength yeah about they win exactly so
yeah u.s. soccer also claims male
players face a more dangerous threat due
to the presence of potentially hostile
fans a spokesperson for the u.s.
national women's team says an argument
that male players have more
responsibility is just plain simple
sexism the women's team launched a
lawsuit against US soccer last March
even they claim they earn their Factory
they do claim they earn at least 38
percent of what their male counterparts
make so I mean I think we can drive a
stake through the heart of the claim
that it that it's a matter of strength
and skill right like no one's arguing
that women are running as fast as men
but that's not what equality is about
it's about valuing people equally
absolutely and they're performing a
sport that is there for entertainment if
the fans are entertained because they
win yeah I can't believe us suck are
actually put these are poor it's just
you know should've been floated and
Beach started yeah they are women's
soccer suing for 67 million dollars in
backpack